hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
here to fill you in on all the big
things that happened in gaming this week
here's what mattered first up fallout 4
second DLC pack wasteland workshop is
out this week the five-dollar dlc is out
on xbox one ps4 and PC right now in
every region except for a just where it
will arrive on the 19th of April
wasteland workshop lets you design cages
for all sorts of creatures and humans
from readers to deathclaws you can tame
them or make them fight each other
whatever suits you DLC also includes a
bunch of new design options for your
settlements like new lighting and
taxidermy creepy earlier this week EA
and respawn entertainment released the
first teaser trailer for titanfall to
the video goes for less than a minute
but it features commentary on the
struggles of being a hero as well as a
drop pod that bears the name James
Macallan who is a soldier from the first
game EA also revealed they will be
officially announcing the game on jun 12
at their pre III briefing and is
expected this time the game will come to
ps4 as well as PC and Xbox one GTA
online is technically free to play so
long as you own GTA 5 but apparently
Rockstar have made over half a billion
dollars on its micro transaction as part
of the lawsuit former Rockstar North
presidents Leslie Benzies was launched
against take two it has been revealed
that GTA online has generated at least
500 million bucks in revenue from its
optional microtransactions to put that
one in context hello fives
microtransactions have brought in over
1.5 million alone from the lawsuit
breeds GTA online has the potential to
achieve the greatest profit margin of
any game created in the GTA franchise
previously take to CEO Strauss Zelnick
called GTA online the gift that keeps on
giving in relation to all the money it
makes from micro transactions currently
the only thing you can spend
the GTA online are shot cards which give
you varying amounts of in-game cash
Microsoft have brought over three more
xbox 360 games to the xbox one by a
backwards compatibility Xbox is Major
Nelson announced on twitter that duke
nukem manhattan project Goro mark of the
wolves and Sonic the fighters are coming
to Xbox one if you've already purchased
any of these for xbox 360 they will now
work on your xbox one or you can find
download links to each of the games in
our story on gamespot if you want to
pick them up now finally and this one is
a bit of a PSA you can play rainbow 6
siege on pc for free right now Ubisoft
has made siege available for free on
Steam and you play up until April 17 you
can get access to the full game
including competitive multiplayer and
terrorist hunt so if you've been
thinking about trying it out now would
be a good time if youre quene head to
the game steam page and click on the
image under the free weekend section the
game is also 30 throught start off now
and the gold version which includes the
season pass is forty percent off so if
you really like it you may want to take
advantage of that let me know what you
cared about this week down in that
comment box and be sure to tell me what
you'll be playing this weekend this week
on site I tell you about five games gone
missing which eventually launched before
that for sho checks out wasteland
workshop arena battles and we love to
gain slot of Thrones that is everything
I have you this week be sure to have
yourselves a great weekend and I will
see you again on Monday